despite best efforts of many of us
canadians are coming down with kovid
time and time again i've been vaccinated
i've got copied four times while being
vaccinated even our fully vaccinated
prime minister isn't immune attending
question period virtually while he gets
over his second case in six months we're
looking at a probable future where if
we're engaging in the kinds of social
behaviors we've become used to in the
last few years
pre-pandemic
we're each looking at two three four
infections per year covet reinfection
depends on a couple of things experts
say new mutations being won federal data
is limited but the latest information
shows while omicron's ba-2 is dominant
in canada sub-variants ba 4 and 5 are
making gains in the u.s those
subvariants already account for 21
percent of infections and european
health officials say they are spreading
more rapidly than others if you were
infected with omicron or any of the sub
variants it doesn't mean that you're
good and protected for the next few
weeks or months or whatever it is that
people think that brings us to infection
immunity there's a growing list of
evidence to suggest omicron specifically
does very little to protect you from
catching the virus again and while covet
is here to stay experts are still
adamant vaccinating the youngest
canadians and boosting the most
vulnerable will help as will strain
specific shots and even new nasal
vaccines if you are still infected it
can help you clear that infection more
quickly and that's the important part
because if you clear the infection
you're less likely to pass it on to
somebody else which is important and it
also gives the virus less chance to
replicate in you diminishing kovid's
ability to evolve meaning less chance at
repeat infection the effects of which we
still know very little about
jamie morocco global news toronto